peut-être que vous êtes une
extraterrestre non je suis au contraire
juste super terrestre et juste du même
vous êtes prêts on va faire une vidéo
[Musique]
vous pensez à quoi là à quoi mon mari
parce que tu viens de m'en parler quand
vous vous regardez dans la glace le
matin vous vous dites quoi ça va plutôt
pas mal ouais c'est vrai quand vous
étiez petit vous lui ressembler à qui à
personne à moi on a déjà attendez de me
recevoir
tout quitter pour le grand amour oui
vraiment
quand avez-vous pleuré pour la dernière
fois
mon dernier parloir
vous changeriez quoi en vous si vous
aviez une baguette magique rien
j'ai pas envie moi j'ai un truc je ne
fais jamais je ne me critique pas je ne
fais pas remarquer aux autres mais
les gens font pas attention à vous
défauts je vais pas leur signaler
dans la vie mon mari
qu'est-ce que vous feriez si vous
n'aviez plus que 24 heures à vivre
jamais
qu'est-ce que la vie vous a appris
jusqu'à maintenant
mais moi j'ai l'impression que je suis
né adulte je n'ai jamais été enfant je
n'ai pas eu l'impression oui mais la
seule passion que j'ai dans la vie c'est
d'apprendre on a tout à prendre des
autres donc la seule chose qui
m'intéresse c'est les rapports humains
ils changent donc j'oublie la question
tellement j'ai essayé de qu'est-ce que
la vie vous a appris jusqu'à maintenant
que j'aime fini mon légende
je comprends pas tout ce qui se passe je
comprends pas quoi j'entendais
l'interview juste avant de peut-être que
vous êtes une extraterrestre non je suis
au contraire juste super terrestre c'est
juste humaine et pour être sûr de ne
rien rater de Inna larditube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu